okay well for people who are joining
this livestream we are doing a design
review design meeting about new features
for from language since we are about to
release version 11.3 this is features
for future versions and we've got a list
of things we're going to look at today
we'll probably go and get beyond these
so let's start off subset cases so what
is this this is a proposal to yes so we
have Tony with us to talk about this so
this this is not evaluatable so I think
the idea here is to generalize sequence
cases to the case in which the objects
of the sequence are separated so it's
right is that frightening yes they can
be separated and in any order these are
the two constraints that we're releasing
well so those constraints could be
different constraints now don't we have
a thing with sequence analysis where we
have least common subsequence all these
various there's a whole family of
functions around sequence alignment that
allow for different kinds of see
sequence alignment I believe we have all
these things about longest common
subsequence longest common sequence do
you recall how that works so those those
have to do with this question about
whether first of all whether the things
are or yeah longest ordered sequence
there we go
middle list perhaps disjoint
okay so this is looking for sequences
that occur in order so are essentially
monotonic that might be disjoint and
you're saying is in your subsets then
you're allowing them to be at any
position as opposed to simply be right
an ordered sequence making sense yes I
think Tony's point is is the pattern
having a pattern rather than looking for
order of things
no I understandable this pattern could
require that those things be in order
right yes the idea of the subject subset
cases is that they don't have to be in
order I understand that but I'm asking
you do you think it's useful I mean
right now we have sequence cases which
requires them to be contiguous and in
order as you say subset cases allows
them to be not contiguous and not in
order I guess the the question here is
in same way that you have sub sequences
and then sequence cases and we have
subsets and this subset cases would we
need a permutation cases or something
like that or do we care I mean it's not
clear that we care I mean if we have sub
sequences okay so sub sequences of like
this would be those okay fine and so
you're saying that is what sequence
cases you know goes so if I say
Quinn's cases fine there are objects to
control over latina things of that okay
okay so now in the subset case you would
imagine that I would get subsets the
subsets have a second argument yes but I
think if you need a list if you want
first
okay so this is what you're arguing for
basically yes and you have a reason to
think that the ordered case is
irrelevant honey
yeah I'm
thinking of writing or finding for
instance subsets of links to their yeah
I don't I don't want to worry writing
the first pattern no I'm not asking
whether subset cases as such as useful
I'm asking whether the ordered case
whether you have an argument for why the
unordered case is definitively more
useful in the ordered case
if if you don't care about
would be more something like tuple cases
women I'm sorry your thing here doesn't
care about the order right correct it
doesn't care right
so I'm asking explain to me so what is
the use case for the thing you have here
so I have a use case and an
implementation from there I'm I have a
list of expressions and I'm trying to
find all pairs for instance but satisfy
a certain pattern constraint okay why do
you want that for instance to implement
a simple version of RDF reasoning that
is my application there you can say
given dead and dead triple had an
additional triple that means in a list
of all triples find certain pairs that
would be subsets of links to okay will
have certain properties and so why isn't
this yes
let's select I mean do we have in my
case I want to extract certain parts of
that expression and then this is more
convenient this case is like I could do
the same to select but it would be more
difficult but so and we don't have a
sequence select okay look I think this
seems reasonable I mean if you have an
implementation I think it's a clear
function what are the weird cases with
variable length patterns and so on it
becomes a little bit more complicated
when you have a pattern test on the
whole pattern for instance and the
variable length patterns are complicated
so what would you do in that case I
don't have
idea for efficient algorithm that would
work in all cases okay but functionality
was a double blank would pick its
elements from any position in the list
is that right so the most
would just be to get all the subsets and
then to cast us on it well hopefully you
can prune that tree a bit better than
that yes okay look I I don't retract to
this function anybody else
object to it I was thinking that when we
introduce a casus function we typically
have an associated position function and
count function and and actually we do
have a sequence position sequence count
oh boy
and what would subset position possibly
do fine good point
I mean sequence position presumably
gives the does it give the span or does
it give them
that was very useful for this particular
thing um yes so it will give them the
list of positions of their respective
elements I see I see
as
- I mean this particular thing is giving
right so yeah right so it can give I see
so yes okay I mean it could do that I
agree it can do that seems awfully
overkill have we ever okay as we ever
needed this not that I remember
but in because Casey's position and
count to have so similar which says it
to go for the three of them no I
understand sequence position that's
perfectly reasonable well let's get some
preliminary implementations of the
subset cases subset positions subset
count and if they really seem you know I
think yeah if they really don't seem
sensible we will make them into function
Pacolet function repository things
otherwise I think that's fine okay
unsorted intersection yes
so these has appeared several times
which is versions and and sorted
versions of intersection a union and
complement I know and this might be use
it appears I agree I agree what would we
want to call them can we call them Union
unsorted or are we gonna call them I
mean it's that um would that be a
reasonable thing to do do we have other
functions that are could have a sorted
option for the existing functions we
can't bear Uggs
yeah well we do have options in them
like suggest yes I know I don't like
having a sorted option I think that's I
think that's kind of crazy
Groff Union does something different
right yes it does aw I don't think we
have finance and unsorted function we we
had the plan of an ordered Association
right right okay but so in this case if
we I mean this is a function that we've
had bubbling around for at least 20
years
um unsorted Union Union unsorted just to
be clear what it would do
we're talking about something where it
is going to take the first instance of
every element and that will determine
its position is that correct yes and is
there any variation on that that we
would want I mean there's a literal
element so it's not really it's like
that's just determining the order in
which the elements occur there's any
notion in which yeah well Union and
intersection are symmetric functions but
complement is not so complement is the
only one in which we might want to do
something different because they so the
first list is padding elements the other
lists are substracting elements hmm so
wonder whether that could cause
different treatment on our live stream
Michael Hale is pointing out he uses
delete duplicates as an unsorted Union
indeed I mean that's the one argument
form of Union yeah the question is what
to do with them it does raise the
question of whether
as a second okay and and this has the
rather ugly same test yeah so what are
you saying with us
to a compliment case I was thinking that
with compliment that the order should be
determined basically by the first
um
than unsorted I was thinking about that
that here we have always this problem of
do we mean keeping the order or not
caring about the order so we call it
something like list Union since list
implies ordering that would suggest that
it might do something different with its
fare our conversation
you
um okay so look it's fairly clear what
these functions do again certainly heard
about these things what what do you
think about unsorted versus you know
Union unsorted versus unsorted Union and
what do we think is there any choice but
um um okay so SG hoist Minh is
suggesting on our live stream a
compliment function that takes account
of multiplicities so you can subtract
assets let's look at his example um
you
I see kind of
Weston as well
how would you do that otherwise
that's removing the elements of the
subsequent sets from the first set
this will be like supporting multisets
for which we don't have functionality in
general what would be another example of
a piece of functionality for multi-sets
it's like it's like computing subsets
with repetition yes or union with
repetition
while we're doing by union with
repetition what would union with
repetition mean
hey geeks I guess we would have to set
maximum number of repetitions and OS
what you say right I see I see I see I
see
so keep accumulating the number of times
that a appears um that yeah keep
accumulating A's until you've got at
most three of them yes I've stood
pointing out that you can get no I mean
join join and sort would do what we're
describing if you allow an infinite
maximum number of occurrences of the
same thing then you can do that if you
want to have a ceiling on the number of
occurrences of something then you would
need something different I mean so this
for example would obviously do that and
if you wanted I mean that there are
multiple different operations so I mean
that the problem is here okay so is it
sorted is it ordered does it account for
multiple us today does it have a maximum
amount but multiplicity I mean I
understand in this compliment case once
just subtracting take away the one take
away the two etc take away elements that
are in the second list and you get left
with a certain set here I mean this is
isn't this a set - type thing isn't that
more what that is
could be Kareem it said would suggest
that we use on what repetitions but but
just I think I see good to me we have
this issue as well with subsets actually
like for example subsets of a a B comma
list too
we'll subsets some subsets yep here you
see it will return a B twice and this
sort of thing has been its opponent
sometimes the factor but it isn't in
fact doing set theory subset so to speak
exactly yep oh boy
this is the mess I don't think this is I
don't think there's a problem we're
gonna solve today the only the only one
of these things that I agree one has
wanted was one need unsorted Union seems
to appear
I mean there's a more general operation
here because what it really is is you're
it's it's like a fold operation in which
you are progressively you know
accumulating stuff but dropping things
that you've seen before but you could
imagine accumulating up to a certain
multiplicity and you could imagine a
bunch of different variants of that for
example I use these functions when I'm
working with indices in tensors because
you have to keep the order in which they
appear and and you have multiple
illnesses from different answers and so
why do you need I don't know why they
and throated Union is the right thing
that because you want to know which in
this is appear and you want to keep the
order in which they appeared you don't
care about how many times they appear
but but it's important to know in which
order they to appear right which makes
the name unsorted Union pretty obscure
example sorted versus unsorted is always
very complicated this is some sort of
Union keep order or something that well
no but I'm saying that what you're
really saying is it's like delete
duplicates um and you
it's like some kind of multi list
version of which is what it obviously is
of delete duplicates um you know there's
a certain argument it is you know it's
joined delete duplicates of join of the
list yeah I think it's kind of a mess
and I'm unconvinced about these things I
mean but the one thing we can do which
is sort of a new path for us is to put
some of these things in the function
repository um and you know which
requires less Design Review that yeah
this this some sander is on the live
stream is suggesting um
well effectively list delete of some
kind for this operation I don't think
it's quite delete it's not quite delete
because delete is a positional I mean
it's it's no no even quite literally
cases it's almost list delete list um
because it's saying yes and any it would
be good to have an naming convention
that keeps the parallelism with
complement Union intersection sure yeah
all right look I don't think we can
solve this today mmm I think you know
there's possible function repository
things maybe it's called list Union I
don't think that's a great name for it
um let's keep going
this is more suggestions from a root
directory file list yeah I agree that
this is really ugly having to do this
really ugly um
and why why does it have an excuse to
not be called names given that the other
one is called file names I mean why not
call it directory file names and how it
take a directory
but I don't think it's a list of all
files under it I think it has the same
you really want infinity there I
wouldn't have thought so by default I
think you just want a list of the of the
files in a given directory
it's the analog of filenames I mean it
just has different defaults from the
file names instead of having a star
there
I see there's sort of an issue there I
mean it could take yeah because the
issue is if it's called file names you
would expect it
oh what a mess you know you would expect
it to take that same file pattern yeah I
mean then the problem is okay
look clearly if I say file names star
dot and B and this is the current
directory okay
comments from people about the naming of
this thing okay can we say something
like fine names oh c'mon you I'm sorry
something I mean I don't know whether
this is already taken file names of all
karate
I see I don't think that's already taken
but let's let some seems to just work
mm-hmm you know that maybe our node
solution I mean I agree that this quote
star thing is ugly do we document all
and file names here I don't know that's
kind of stupid and ugly I think we
should document all and it's already
there were details section
for I sink I'm looking oh yeah all can
be used in place of star okay well maybe
we should promote that to the primary
documentation for that at least update
the examples that use we're hot - it's
hard to hear you sorry I was just saying
or update some of the examples to
demonstrate it I agree
Sandra's pointing out the blank also
works yeah I think all it's a nice thing
to put there I kind of think update the
examples perhaps promote this into the
top level documentation here
and leave it at that
okay let's keep going here we're going
to look at some have a bunch of
suggestions here I want to talk a little
bit about this business about maybe this
is not the right discussion not the
right group for this but um discussion
about animated graphics and so on and
the possibility of having what amounts
to a time axis in graphics
so you know this is something I've long
been thinking about you know it's
essentially a timed you know one version
of this would be a timed plot where you
could say you know plot X plus T let's
say sine of X plus T and then it's you
know X 0 to 10 or something and then
this t variable is actually I think it
would be like this I'm sorry that would
be like this where you have both a a
position and a time variable or making
sense now there's a question of the
constant proportionality between seconds
and for example I mean how does that
that you know we've got some analog of
that so for example in animate we have
got how does this work what is the
correspondence between the time actual
time I think it's this animation rate
that determines the okay people's
comments on this time to plot idea so
these would return something similar to
manipulate yes but well I think the main
objective here is to be able to write
you know the main place that gets
interesting is when you have graphics
and when you have and again this is not
probably thought through and maybe this
is the wrong group for this I think
maybe we should have a separate
discussion specifically about this um I
mean this is basically you know this is
related to the whole object graphics
business and so on alright let's let's
take a look now at my general list here
um
vertex texture coordinates this is a new
this is the thing where um again this
may be the wrong group for this I think
this is the wrong group we don't have
Brett here doing today no we don't okay
so what's an automatically yeah the main
point is that that there are several
options like fill fit stretch kinds of
things are all different possibilities
for what you want you know texture
mapping to do yeah we do that in
Geographics because Geographics we use
textures a lot and in fact we are
internally doing automatic computation
of that vertex texture coordinates I see
okay so again this you know fill fit
stretch etc are among the possibilities
for what you want to happen mm-hmm um I
think in this version we got something
what did we get in this version we got
automatic okay come on
into this come on what is that we fix
that please yes that's a bit
embarrassing we find out why dqa did not
catch that
okay anyway wrong group let's get that
on a list for a graphics review along
with this one here okay okay yes okay um
whatever happened to array Association
otherwise known as apply keys and so on
did that did that already get um did we
already move that to implementation not
yet that's on my plate I have been
discussing with severe about it and the
relation with data side but but not yet
have an understanding addition okay
all right next on my list is stuff to do
with the chat system I don't think
that's for this group either great find
character encoding do you know the
status of that oh that is something I
need to pinky he and she she was working
on it initially and I think though she's
focusing on take input okay
how about she doesn't drop that yes I
will make sure that she doesn't okay so
we also another thing we had on the list
is session information or session data
that is some kind of data set or
Association of detailed information
about a session yes we need to we need
to basically design it more so that we
have someone to work on it okay alright
we have the column map column delete
business which I hope you guys are
working on yes yes and I'm looking into
that okay whatever happened to flattened
well I haven't discussed that with the
Thai the idea is I think it's to a pole
he has more concerns of course it's I
remember right now so it would be better
to have that conversation with that he
has some some concerns about
okay so Sushma can you get that put
together yep okay oh yeah there was a
discussion about memory um this whole
memory available business right so the
question is for example in the cloud
where there's user memory allocation
limits how does this work
I think that's unknown at this point
all right whatever happened my next
listing here is line through circle
through and so on what's happened to
those we have no I I went to say that
last time we stopped at that and we
wanted to discuss this again but yeah we
can discuss it right now too
okay I have next on my list after this
is geo list plot 3d yes that's also for
me so I mean right now developing the
language of datums for innovation and
which is going to be important here and
it's also ultimately this is going to
put things on a sphere yes if I say just
generically Keolis plot 3d of jewel
range is all that's just going to give
the whole world isn't it well the
spheres
we considered like a particular
projection here in general we may want
to have let's say the XY plane being in
some projection and then the C axis
being elevation and and and so we need
to add the possibility of saying the
projection is the sphere itself is
healing well actually I got distracted
looking at live stream stuff Michael
Hale is just strongly supporting column
map yeah we all agree it's it's been not
there for too long um okay sorry back
back to journalist plot 3d so what are
you saying you're saying that the goal
is to project the data onto a sphere in
the case of cheerless plot 3d or what no
what I'm saying is that that should be
one possibility in many other cases
where one will not want a curved result
one will won't say for example imagine
you want that yearly spot 3d of the
relief of the u.s. so we might want to
to have some sort of base which is a
projection of the US and then vertically
the elevations and so this function
needs to take at your projection option
and then one of the possibilities and
I'm using right now globe but we have to
name it could be a projection which is a
3d as fears itself I see so the question
is it sort of the what you're doing is
it is an I mean there to differ
questions
one is that you are getting height
information and the other is that you
are presenting like positions of cities
on a sphere right or for example you are
presenting things like satellite
positions relative to the relative to a
sphere
well what I would say is that in the
same way that we can have the map of the
u.s. in multiple projections we can have
also relief a 3d relief of the u.s. in
those respective projections with with a
flat base and then you can distort the
the looking from above you can distort
the shape of such-and-such a mountain
right you know you can distort the base
even though the height is but I mean for
example the question is is the vector
that goes from the base to the top of
the mountain is it a vertical vector or
is it a vector that's pointing you know
like a head you know like a like some
kind of you know explosion from the
center radial vector right so we need
was both possibilities so my plan was to
have geo projection goes to say globe or
something or Fierro ellipsoid and then
the base of the US will be curved
corresponding to the curvature of the
earth yeah but in the case of clear
graphics geo projection arrows sphere
would do what well we could have it and
I wasn't planning to do anything there
but it could simply put the map on the
sphere it's a flat map on the sphere
yeah but man is it going to make a 3d
graphic or a 2d graphic it's a 3d but
that's why it doesn't sound correct yeah
I don't think it's correct
[Music]
but then I'm still a little bit confused
here and I'm not sure it's a single
function yes it is but it's problem that
we need a geographic 3d and then again a
series of visualization functions that's
called geographic scope what do you
think the real use cases for this you
think it's to show elevation data in
which case we're gonna have to have a
scaling function that determines because
otherwise you know I mean the earth is
extremely flat and some you know or is
this primarily to actually show a
picture I mean like you know a morph
Alpha obviously we have you know okay
let's just be clear what we're talking
about here we're um
you know I don't know let's say
you
something like this um if you do
we should get why doesn't that show us
say I thought that showed us her on the
globe plot doesn't huh um what's an
example of something that does I guess
if we ask for yeah if we ask for
something like this
I think we will get
okay show 3d
that other one doesn't allow the
possibility of showing 3d
not a very exciting 3d picture but
there's the 3d version of that so that's
what I was imagining
we would be talking about um for many of
these 3d things is actually showing the
sphere like this as a 3d graphic yes but
I can imagine as well that we could have
some sort of a cool rectangular base in
which then we put them I understand the
elevation data the elevation or for
example we put the you know the airplane
trajectory flying overhead exactly
because sometimes it may be I don't know
for a 3d printing object we do want to
have an exactly flat base so sure we
also might want you know if we're
showing this is where these two planes
you know flew across the US or something
and they got I don't know what but Tim
yeah okay fair enough I understand I'm a
little skeptical but it's one function I
mean I'm kind of suspecting that there
are different options that you need when
the whole thing is going to be on a
sphere that when it's on a flat base
because for example yeah okay
all right to be continued on that one
let's see I'm looking at how is the
around business coming along for numbers
well uncertainty yeah that's that's
progressing and it should be ready for
the next question okay what happened to
integer fractional part is that being
done that's a very lower priority thing
we can do it but we haven't done it yet
whatever happened to bitwise function
bit function I don't even remember yeah
I don't think so we do discuss this in
any only meeting okay so the idea of
this is just like we have bitwise you
know bit XOR okay so also I mean to be
honest this is a this is a fine function
repository thing if nothing else um you
understand what it's doing it's doing
the analog a bit XOR but this is in this
case this is like a boolean function but
that's like boolean function what that's
doing is it's doing the bitwise boolean
function of so let's let's take it
explicitly that's like 150 comma 3 and
that is if we say ABC here that will be
um if we say boolean and my's of that
okay that's xor
that's the I'm sure if I minimize that
with respect to X or it will show us
what it is good
they convert maybe not minimize
I think I just did
but
whatever okay um yeah there we go so so
that thing is XOR okay so the point is
um
uhh
the point is some this is a pretty minor
thing but the point is just to be able
to take a function of bits
and be able to apply it it's it's sort
of a you know it's a bitwise map
yeah
I mean you know there's a whole bunch of
functions around byte arrays that we
really should have I mean this is this
is essentially yeah I mean we could
consider this bitwise map well it's
actually bitwise map thread
unfortunately
you
um and it's not obvious that this is the
right way to do it but that could be
that one wants a boolean function in
that a reason to have supported bit the
bit X or bit or etc to begin with was
the desire to attain huge efficiency and
we can do that because they're all
they'll map to see functions doesn't
happen in this general case so that I
don't know that there's much advantage
doesn't it I mean it's the the fact that
those things are machine instructions
you know I mean you can implement
because we've got at least four boolean
functions we can turn those into a
collection of machine instructions the
way I just did it right you can always
do it with DN F and C enough and then
you still get the factor of 64 speed-up
because you're able to do it in parallel
across all the bits and the word
completely unconvinced about that but
definitely that's how we do the cellular
automaton function for example um we
should be wrapping this meeting we have
a suggestion from sander on our live
stream about bin lists by which is an
interest
and function
you
let me think about this for a second am
I going to be able to click on this and
is it going to just show us a community
post the sit-in here then lists by
okay so this is the determining function
that determines what will put things in
the same bin right that's the idea here
so bin lists on its own how does it do
that I know that we have funny stories
to run by no that's not the same thing
because because what no we don't but I
mean that's not the same thing the point
here this is more like gather by
how does this relate together by
okay so Sanders pointing out you can bin
M dimensional data in n dimensions
well it seems interesting and perhaps we
can look at this and I think we have to
continue another time
um not our most uh um okay gather by
does not give one the empty bins it's
the complaint well maybe that's a
problem with gather by maybe gather by
needs an option that's like the null
records option for um you know in in the
case of string matching right so that is
an interesting question whether
no but that doesn't work because that's
a different
I'm not sure I understand how bin lists
by determines what the set of possible
bins is okay I think today has not been
our most productive one of these
meetings but um um I think we are out of
time right now and to be continued next
next time all right
seals